liegt der warp antrieb in greifbarer
nähe also hat er eine chance realisiert
zu werden
eine voraussetzung dafür ist dass wir
negative masse erzeugen und genau das
ist gelungen die fachwelt träumt jetzt
schon von neuartigen laser in
supercomputern und eben sogar einen warp
antrieb ist das tatsächlich realistisch
und wie genau lässt sich negative masse
erzeugen klicks um science-fiction
herzlich willkommen
danke für den themenvorschlag über
whatsapp wie er da dabei sein könnt und
themen vorschlagen kommt und vor allem
die unzuverlässige abo box von youtube
überlistet das erfahrt ihr am ende des
videos mehr als klar ist dass sich ein
objekt wie beispielsweise einen fußball
den wir anstoßen sich tatsächlich auch
nach vorne weg aktion gleich reaktion
oder dass ein wassertropfen aus dem
wasserhahn nach unten fällt und nicht
nach oben das alles lernen wir schon
wenn wir noch sehr klein sind bei
negativer masse ist das anders hier gilt
unser grundsatz der alltagswelt nicht
mehr
denn wenn man sie anstößt bewegt sie
sich in die entgegengesetzte richtung
sie beschleunigt also rückwärts wenn man
einen fußball anstupsen würde würde er
sich auf einen zu bewegen
negative masse zu erzeugen das war lange
ein traum der wissenschaftswelt und es
ist tatsächlich das erste mal gelungen
notwendig dafür ist aufwendige
kühltechnik rubidium atome wurden auf
wenige bruchteile eines grades über dem
absoluten nullpunkt von minus 273 15
grad celsius abgekühlt und zwar mit
hilfe eines lesers dieser
aggregatzustand wird als bose einstein
kondensat bezeichnet die materie verhält
sich da nicht so wie einzelne teilchen
sondern wie ein einziges atom und eher
wie eine welle
doch immer noch besitzt sie eine normale
positive masse vereinfacht gesagt wurden
die atome dann durch gezielte
manipulation mit einem laser geschüttelt
und sie veränderten ihre bewegung das
nennt sich spin bahn kopplung und schon
bewegen sich die rubidium atome nicht
die die richtung in die man sie
geschubst hat sondern die
entgegengesetzte die materie fällt sich
also so als hätte sie eine negative
masse sie beschleunigt rückwärts dazu
einer der beteiligten forscher michael
fox es sieht aus als wenn das rubidium
gegen eine unsichtbare mauer stoßen
würde
das forschungsteam vermutet dass
negative masse nicht nur im labor
sondern auch natürlich vorkommen ran
beispielsweise in neutronensternen oder
schwarzen löchern oder bei der
rätselhaften dunklen energie also
wirklich nur unter extremen bedingungen
wir hatten ja schon mal über dieses
thema berichtet aber jetzt kommen doch
was da zu einem anderen us
amerikanischen forschungsteam ist ein
weiterer schritt gelungen sie haben
quasi teilchen erzeugt die sich so
verhalten wie negative masse diese
so genannten polar addons erzeugten sie
ohne kühlung steigt dessen manipulierten
sie photonen des lichts und kombinierten
sie mit sehr speziellen kleinen teilchen
den sogenannten e zitronen das ergebnis
partikel die halb materie und halb licht
sind manchmal auch als magic das
bezeichnet also so etwas wie magischer
staub möglich wurde das durch ein gerät
mit zwei speziellen spiegeln die einen
optisch micro hohlraum formen die farben
des lichtspektrums werden aufgeteilt und
quasi angeordnet das licht interagiert
mit einem ultra dünnen halbleiter aus
molybdän diese linie daraus entstehen
dann die polaritäten die sich ebenso wie
negative massa verhalten bei der
experimente lassen die fachwelt träumen
von neuartigen laser beispielsweise die
kaum energie benötigen aber auch neue
arten von supercomputern könnten mit
diesem wissen entwickelt werden und
negativem asse gilt außerdem als
voraussetzung für einen möglichen warp
antrieb ja von dem science fiction fans
wie ich zum beispiel schon lange tot
denn der theorie zufolge muss ein
funktionsfähiger warp antrieb in der
lage sein das raum zeit gebiet um einen
raum stift so zu verändern dass sich
start und zielpunkt näher kommen konkret
muss sich die raumzeit vor dem
raumschiff zusammenziehen und hinter ihm
ausbreitenden da sich die raumzeit
selbst überlegt schnell ausbreitet
könnte das objekt dann in einer blase in
einer art blase mitreißen dafür ist wie
gesagt eine negative energiedichte
wichtig ist könnte also sein
ja es könnte sein wenn ihr also nicht
zum bob antrieb und allen anderen themen
verpassen wollt dann endet meine
telefonnummer bei whatsapp und den
anderen messenger nur dann verpasst er
kein video denn die abo box auf youtube
die ist ja immer ein bisschen
unvollständig dann erfahrt ihr von mir
vor allen anderen vom neuesten video
täglich garantiert einfach hier
draufklicken und zur begrüßung habe ich
ein kleines goodie und am besten auch
meinen schwesterkanal klicks um social
media abonnieren dafür erfährt er zum
beispiel warum die video days ausfallen
ja und nicht die genau die glocke
vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür
auch draufklicken ebola erreicht
millionenstadt mit der dramatischen
entwicklung dieses ausbruchs im
falls es verpasst haben solltet
ansonsten bis dann bleibt da